في الخامس من يونيو الماضي اغلقت دول
الحصار مجالها الجوي امام الطائرات
القطريه ضم اجراءات اخرى وذلك في خطوه غير
مسبوقه راى فيها خبراء انتهاكا للقانون
الدولي وضعت تساؤلات عن جدوى الاتفاقات
الدوليه الناظم لحركه الطيران المدني
واهمها اتفاقيه شيكاجو وعن حقوق الاف
المسافرين الذين تضرروا من هذا
الاجراء وقد رفعت دوله قطر شكوى بهذا
الشان مدعومه بالوثائق الى الى منظمه
الطيران المدني التابعه للامم المتحده وفي
ختام اجتماعها دعت المنظمه جميع الدول
الاعضاء الى التعاون لضمان سلامه الطيران
والالتزام بالاتفاقيات الدوليه تقرير محمد
ابراهيم ما كان يفترض انه خلاف سياسي افرز
بالتداعي ازمات عده منها ما اصاب عصب حريه
التنقل الجوي بل وامن وسلامه الطيران
وعرضه للخطر في سابقه تاريخيه هي الاولى
دول عربيه تغلق مجالها الجوي امام طيران
دوله عربيه اخرى الاغلاق شمل حتى مسارات
الطوارئ وعطل خطوط الامان المعروفه على
المستوى الدولي الازمه الخليجيه التي دخلت
شهرها الثاني خلفت اثارا جسيمه على كثير
من المسافرين القادمين الى قطر والمغادرين
وزادت اعباء ومسافات الرحلات فضلا عن
الخسائر التي تكبدتها شركات طيران عده ليس
القطريه فحسب بل شركه كات طيران تابعه
لدول رباعي الحصار ذاتها السعوديه
والامارات والبحرين ومصر هي اذا عرقله
لحركه المسافرين وارباك لخطوط ومسارات
الطيران الدولي في منطقه تعد الاكثر كثافه
وعقده استقطاب عالميه من والى وجهاتها
ومحطاتها الاخيره وفي ظل تعطل الهيئه
العربيه للطيران المدني التابعه للجامعه
العربيه اسوه بتعطل كيان الجامعه ذاته
كانت المنصه الدوليه مقصد قطر لوضع اوراق
على الطاوله جراء الاضرار البالغه التي
لحقت بحركه الطيران والمسافرين بناء على
طلب قطر عقدت منظمه الطيران المدني الدولي
التابعه للامم المتحده ايكاو اجتماعا في
مدينه مونتريال الكنديه لمناقشه قضيه
الحصار الجوي وقدمت قطر ملفا مدعوما
بالوثائق بشان انتهاك المواثيق الدوليه
وتعريض امن وسلامه الطيران للخطر بفعل
قرارات غير مسبوقه وغير محسوبه العواقب و
تلك الدول الاربع اعضاء في المنظمات
الدوليه التي انشاتها اتفاقيه شيكاغو منذ
عقود بهدف تنظيم عمل الطيران الدولي
وتسهيله والاهم تجنيب الملاحه من اي اخطار
محدقه وضمان سلامه الاجواء بما فيه مصلحه
الانسانيه جمعاء وقد اكد وزير المواصلات
والاتصال القطري جاسم بن سيف الصليطي ان
ما جرى من قبل دول الحصار هو تع صريح على
جميع المواثيق والاعراف والاتفاقيات
الدوليه المتعلقه بالطيران
قانونيه وواجهه الشكوى القطريه التي تسعى
لايجاد حدول لها بعيدا عن الاستقطاب
السياسي استبقت ه دول الحصار بمحاوله
تعطيل الاجتماع وعندما لم تفلح التفت على
القضيه باعلان تخصيص ممرات طوارئ جويه
لعبور الطائرات القطريه في اجوائها وفق
وكاله الانباء السعوديه فان الدول الاربع
فتحت تسعه ممرات طوارئ للخطوط القطريه وهو
ما نفته وزاره المواصلات والهيئه العامه
للطيران المدني القطريه اكدت ان الدوحه لم
تتسلم حتى الان اشعارا من ايكاو يثبت صحه
ادعاءه الدول الاربع الارتباك الواضح من
دول الحصار قبيل اجتماع منظمه ايكاو يراه
خبراء ناجما عن اجراءاتهم التي تعد
انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الدولي حيث يحق
للدول ان تغلق مطاراتها وموانئها ونقاط
حدودها لكن من غير المقبول باي حال من
الاحوال منع الطيران المدني لدوله اخرى من
عبور اجوائها لك ان تمنع مع الهبوط لكن
ليس العبور وممرات الطوارئ فذلك فتح باب
لكوارث جويه ليست بالحسبان عدا عن الارباك
في حركه الطيران الدولي والاهم التاثير
على المسافرين في المنطقه وانحاء العالم
اولئك الباحثين عن اجابات حول سبل الخروج
من هذه الازمات وعم من يتحمل المسؤوليه عن
معاناتهم للحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من مونتريال بكندا مراسل الجزيره
مراد هاشم كما ينضم الينا من لندن الكس
ماتشيس الخبير في شؤون الملاحه الجويه
نبدا اولا مع مراسلنا مراد هاشم مراد ما
هي اهم
الملاحظات التي جرت او تمت فيما يتعلق
بالشكوى التي قدمتها قطر الى المنظمه كذلك
ما هي تلك
الدفوع المقدمه من دوله قطر والدفوع
المقدمه من دول
الحصار
نعم في الواقع جمال قطر حققت ما كانت تريد
تحقيقه على وجه السرعه وهو ان فتح وهو فتح
ممرات ملاحيه دوليه هذا الامر كانت تطالب
به قطر وكانت دول الحصار تمانع الى ان
اطرت الى هذه اتخاذ هذه الخطوه وتقديم
وثائق تثبت انها بالفعل فتحت هذه الممرات
قبيل انعقاد اجتماع ايكاو
بدقائق تحدثنا الى وزير النقل القطري جاسم
بن سيف السليطي الذي ابدا ارتياحه من هذه
النتيجه وتوقع ان
تشهد الملاحه الجويه من والى قطر في ضوء
هذه الخطوه الكثير من التحسن خلال الفتره
الماضيه وقال واعرب عن الاسف ان ان
لاضطرار قطر اللجوء الى محفل دولي كي تحقق
نتيجه كهذه لكن لا يزال امام قطر الكثير
من المطالب التي تسعى لتحقيقها عبر ايكاو
وان لم تكن
ب وان لم تكن
ملحه كما يتعلق الامر بفتح الممرات الجويه
الدوليه اليوم وزير النقل القطري قدم
وقبيل الاجتماع ايضا طلبا
للمنظمه يتعلق ب ان تحصل قطر على معلومات
الطيران الجوي الخاصه بها وهو طلب يعني
بكلمات اخرى الغاء اتفاقيه ثنائيه ما بين
قطر والبحرين كانت تخول البحرين صلاحيه
اداره
الاجواء الملاحيه فوق قطر وكذلك في محيطها
الوزير النقل القطري اعتبر ان البحرين
الغت هذه الاتفاقيه من جانبها حينما شاركت
بعمليه الحصار واغلاق الاجواء امام
الطيران القطري وبالتالي هذه هي المرحله
الثانيه مرحله حركه قطر بهذا الشان وهي
استعاده السيطره واداره
الامور المتعلقه بمجالها الجوي المرحله
الثالثه جمال ستكون متعلقه
بالاجواء والملاحه الجويه فوق اجواء هذه
الدول الاربع فوق قطر سوف تستند الى
الماده 84 من
اتفاقيه فوق اليابسه صحيح جمال سوف تستند
الى الماده 84 من اتفاقيه شيكاجو التي تنص
هي تعترف بسياده الدول على مجالاتها
الجويه ولكنها تنص نص بشكل صريح الا يكون
هناك تمييز ومن هذا الباب تدفع قطر ب انه
من ان هناك ثمه التمييز وان هذا الحظر
ايضا يعرض سلامه الطيران الجوي ل وامنه
للخطر وبالتالي هذهه هي المعركه القادمه
المجلس التنفيذي لاكو سوف ويذهب في اجازه
لثلاثه اشهر وسيعاود الانعقاد للنظر في
هذه القضيه في مراحلها اللاحقه الدول
الاربع طبعا حاولت الدفع باتجاه
انها تدافع او بالنهايه تمارس حقها
السيادي
وكذلك تضمن امنها القومي و والى اخر من
مبررات
كما تعل تعلنه في مواقفها ووسائل اعلامها
ولكن قرار المنظمه اليوم او وتوصيته بان
على جميع الدول بان تنصاع لاتفاقيه شيكاغو
كان رساله واضحه لهذه الدول على نحو محدد
شك شكرا لك مراد هاشم مراسل الجزيره
متحدثا الينا من مونتريال في كندا و وزير
المواصلات القطري جاسم بن سيف اليطي عبر
عن ارتياحه لنتائج الاجتماع الاستثنائي
لمنظمه الطيران المدني الدولي ايكاو وقال
الوزير في تصريحات الجزيره ان حركه
الملاحه الجويه من والى قطر ستشهد تحسنا
ملموسا بعدما استجابت دول الحصار لمطلب
قطر بفتح ممرات ملاحيه في الاجواء الدوليه
وعبر الوزير عن الاسف لاضطرار قطر الى
اللجوء الى محفل دولي لتحقيق ذلك مضيفا ان
قطر كانت تامل في حل المشكله بدون اللجوء
الى المجتمع
الدولي اول شيء تحقق اللي هو كنا نطلب
جميع الدول الامتثال
لاتفاقيات شيكاجو
والاتفاقيات المنظمه لهذا العمل وملحقات
اتفاقيات شيكاجو فكان هذا الهدف الاساسي
ان على الجميع الامتثال بما ان دوله قطر
ممتله قولا وفعلا بهذه الاتفاقيه نطلب من
الجميع الامتثال
فهذا شيء من اللي تحقق والمجلس اصر على
على استخدام كلمه امتثال نظرا لان في تعدي
صار على الامن والسلامه
الجويه ليس كلامي انا فقط انما كلام
المجتمع الدولي 36 دوله كانت موجوده
ضمنيا
الناس جميع الاعضاء تكلموا في هذا الموضوع
وهو يخص الامن والسلامه الجويه خصوصا ان
البند الذي تقدمت فيه دوله قطر من اتفاقيه
شيكاجو هو البند 54 ان وهو يختص بامن
وسلامه الطيران طيب ما الذي تتوقع عونه من
هذه الدول الان بعد هذه
التوصي صراحه اتوقع منهم الامتثال
لاتفاقيات شيكاجو ليس فقط للممرات الدوليه
لان هذا الامر العاجل اللي طلبت طلبت دوله
قطر التدخل فيه لكن الامتثال لكامل
اتفاقيات شيكاجو للبند 84 بحق
المرور لجميع الدول ولا يجوز التمييز بين
دوله واخرى كما تعرف ان ان هذه الدول
استعملت هذا الحق حقا تعسفيا وفرته على
الطائرات المسجله فقط في دوله قطر وهذا ما
ما يعد تعسفا في في استخدام الحقوق نظرا
ان ان ان الاتفاقيه نصت صراحه يجوز لك
استخدام هذا الحق لكن دون التمييز اي تمنع
جميع الطائرات هذا حق سيادي لك اما تمنع
طيارات وتختار طيارات اخرى باي اسباب
واهيه لا يوجد لا يوجد لك حق في هذا
الموضوع وهذا البند اللي احنا استندنا
عليه ان شاء الله وقدمنا وجالسين نكمل
الخطوات لانها خطوات كبيره جدا للملف
القطري في في في اتفاقيه شيكاجو البند
84 اذا كان هذا وزير النقل والمواصلات
القطري متحدثا عن الانجاز الذي تم لصالح
قطر في المنظمه الدوليه مازال معنا الخبير
في شؤون الملاحه الجويه الكس ماتشيس سيد
ماتشيس ماذا يعني هذا الانجاز بالنسبه
لقطر
وكذلك الى اين
سيؤدي كري مساء الخير هو انجاز لقطر لان
الشيء الاساسي الذي حققوه اليوم هو تاكيد
المنظمه على اتفاقيه شيكاجو واتفاقيه
العبور
وتم اعلانه هذا اليوم عن طريق المنظمه
الدوليه للطيران المدني حول
مساله ان كل الول البحرين والامارات
العربيه ومصر لتوقيعها اتفاقيه وتوقيع
البحرين السعوديه للاتفاقيه شيكاغو لذلك
مطالبتها بفتح الاجواء وخاصه بالنسبه
للامارات والبحرين
وايضا مصر لانها موقعه على اتفاقيه شيكاجو
وهي الاتفاقيه المهمه التي تسمح
بطيران الطائرات عبر الاجواء الدوليه
والتي تم اغلاقها امام الطيران القطري
كانت دول الحصار استبقت اجتماع المنظمه
منظمه الطيران المدني باعلان فتح ممرات
جويه للطيران القطري كيف تقرا هذه الخطوه
الاستباقيه قبل حوالي 24 ساعه من اجتماع
المنظمه
الدوليه كان هذا الامر مربكا في حقيقه
الامر بدا وكانه نوع من محاوله يائسه من
قبل السعوديه والامارات ومصر والبحرين من
اجل تقويه ذرائع وخاصه قبل جلسه الاستماع
في ايكاو من اجل السماح بتسع ممرات جويه
في حاله
الطوارئ السماح للطائرات القطريه
باستخدامها لم يكن الامر واضحا لانه ليس
هنالك بامكاننا اكيد ان اي من الطيران
القطري او اي من الطائرات القطريه
بامكانها ان تدخل هذه الممرات اذا ما
واجهت طوارئ ايضا اذا ما كان هنالك قواعد
معينه
للطوارئ عبر اجوائهم كانت الاجواء ولحد
الان مغلقه امام الطائرات المسجله تحت اسم
قطر لتلك لن يسمح للطائرات باي حال من
الاحوال المرور بها يبدو وكان هذا الامر
باكمله كانه محاوله يائس لدعم دوافعهم قبل
جلسه الاستماع اعتقد اننا لن نسمع المزيد
حول هذا المر الامر بعد ان اعلنت المنظمه
الدوليه للطيران المدني تاكيدها على
احترام القانون لذلك على تلك الدول يجب
عليها ان تحترم القواعد التي اكدت عليها
ايكاو ان تقوم برفع الحصار وفتح الممرات
الجويه الدوليه امام الطيران القطري
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لم توقع على
اتفاقيه
لها ان تب اجواءها مغل امام الطيران
القطري ذكرت نقطه مهمه وهي احترام دول
الحصار
الى الدعوه دعوه المنظمه الدوليه في يعني
فورا الطيران المدني في قطر كان نفى هيئه
كان نفى صحه ما نشر عن تخصيص ممرات طوارئ
للطيران القطري هل تعتقد ان كي يتوجب
الاحترام لهذا الاجراء اتخاذ اجراءات
معينه من قبل المنظمه على دول الحصار بحيث
التاكد من انها فعلا تنفذ مطلب المنظمه
الدوليه كان هذا الوضع استثنائي بالنسبه
للايكاو لاننا كما نعرف فان ايكيو هي
منظمه تابعه للامم المتحده للطيران المدني
التي لا تصدر اي قوانين ملزمه لكنها تقوم
بوضع عقود كجزء من الامم المتحده تقوم
الدول بالتوقيع عليها وعندما يتم التوقيع
على تلك الاتفاقيات اذا تصبح ملزمه
قانونيا اذا ما تم تقديمها للمحاكم كان
هذا الموقف استثنائي لان ايكيو لم تقم باي
شيء مماثل باستثناء كوبا هم ليسوا لا
يتدخلون غالبا في العلاقات الدبلوماسيه او
الخلافات السياسيه بين الدول او بين عده
دول وخاصه في دول الخليج في هذه الحاله
لذلك كان استثنائيا ان وجود عدد مثل هذه
الجلسات الاستماع التي طالبت بها قطر
لكنها محقه في القيام بذلك لانه في نهايه
الامر ثلاثه من اصل اربعه من الدول
المحاصره هي دول موقعه على اتفاقيه العبور
ان اتفاقيه العبور تعود لايكيا ولذلك
التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيات هم يسمحون
بالمرور الحر لاي طائران عبر اجوائهم
وايضا خلال موضوع المعلومات العام الخاص
بالطيران ذلك كونهم دول موقعه لهذه
الوثيقه هم يعطون
ايكيا التاكيد اننا لن نغلق اجوائنا وهذا
الامر يشكل نوع من النفاق بالنسبه
للامارات لانهم يدعون الى فتح الاجواء
وايضا اكدوا كانوا كان هنالك جدل حول
الولايات المتحده من اجل فتح خطوط طيران
اكبر نحو العالم لذلك له بتجاهلهم اتفاقيه
الطيران التي وقعوا عليها وتم عندما تم
اعلان الحصار واغلاق اجوائهم امام الطيران
القطري كان هذا الامر كافيا لقطر للذهاب
الى ايكاو وان التاكيد على احترام هذه
الاتفاقيات واعطاء تلك الدول خاصه انها
قامت بالتوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيات لذلك من
المهم جدا الان وبهذه التوصيات مع ايكي
فان الامارات والبحرين ومصر يجب عليهم ان
يحترموا التوصيات هذه المنظمه التابعه
للامم المتحده وان يفتحوا اجوائهم وان
يلتزموا باتفاقيه العبور الذي وقعوا عليه
وان يسمحوا بالطيران القطري والطائرات
المسجله تحت اسم قطر بالطيران في اجوائها
فوق ذلك هناك اناس
تضرروا بسبب اغلاق
الاجواء هل لقطر الحق في ان ملاحقات
قانونيه عبر منظمات او هيئات دول
ل تعويض هؤلاء الذين تضرروا نتيجه
ذلك هذا الشيء لن يتم القيام به عبر ايك و
لذلك مطالبه باي تعويضات لن يتم اطلاقه من
قبل المنظمه لكن بالتاكيد فان قطر لديها
الحق باطلاق قضايا قانونيه وايضا قام مثلا
اكبر الباكر الرئيس التنفيذي لقطر ايريز
قال انه سيحاول اطلاق قضايا قانونيه من
اجل الحصول على تعويضات لاي ضرر لاغلاق
الاجواء وهذا الامر يتعلق بايقاف الخطوط
وربما الكلفه الاضافيه للوقود او الكلفه
الاضافيه للخدمات
لانه ايضا محاوله من قطر الخطوط القطريه
ايجاد طرق بديله للوصول الى وجهاتها لذلك
لن يتم الامر عبر المنظمه لكن لقطر الحق
التحرك بشكل مستقر وكما قلت فان الخطوط
الجويه القطريه تنوي القيام بذلك الكس
ماتش راس الخبير في شؤون الملاحه الجويه
متحدثا الينا من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك في
الاونه الاخيره باتت السعوديه قبله لعدد
من القيادات العراقيه البارزه بدءا من
رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي مرورا بوزير
داخليته واخيرا زعيم التيار الصدري مقتضى
الصدر فما هي اهداف هذا التقارب بين
الجانبين هذا ما يبحثه حسن جمول في الملف
الثاني من الحصاد